MALE SPEAKER: So thank
you all for coming,
especially given that we're
on the far ends of campus
and that it kind of
pretended to rain today.
I'm here to introduce
Kevin Blake.
I'll talk for 10 seconds.
I first saw Kevin
perform in San Francisco
and was absolutely
blown away and thought
he needed to come to Google.
So, without anything
more, Kevin Blake.
KEVIN BLAKE: Hello, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
As he said, my name
is Kevin Blake.
My real name is
Kevin Blake Ferguson,
but my stage name is Kevin
Blake, so do not mess it up.
Call me Kevin Ferguson
off the stage.
When I go out there
we can chat later.
You can call me Kevin Ferguson.
Now it's Kevin Blake.
And as he said, I do
magic up in San Francisco.
My stage show, I perform
once or twice a month.
You guys should
all come as well.
But I'm a magician.
I'm also a storyteller
and a performer.
When people ask what I do,
I usually refer to myself
as a performer, which
is admittedly almost as
vapid in use as a
descriptor as consultant
is in the business world.
But it still seems
better than "magician."
Now I don't like "magician"
for two reasons--
although you can still call
me it-- for two reasons.
One, I don't consider
myself to be very creepy;
and two, I don't do
the types of magic
that you probably think of
when you think of a magician.
For example, I don't
do bunnies out of hats.
And at no point during
the next 45 minutes
or so will any cards
or women be vanished,
produced, transformed,
restored, teleported, levitated,
or penetrated.
It's very important; there
will be no penetration on stage
today.
I promise you.
I am a magician, but
I want to show you
guys some-- I want to talk
to you guys about some very
interesting things that
I like about magic today.
Now, the topic of
today's talk is
"Creating Magical Experiences."
I don't know if
there's something
different on the email list.
But don't concern
yourself with that.
How many people in the
audience tonight are engineers?
Engineers?
Yeah?
We have-- designers?
Any designers?
Yeah?
One, two.
Marketers?
Yeah?
You guys are all people who
create experiences for others.
And this is the same thing
that I do as a performer.
And I'd like to talk
to you guys about what
I've learned over the
past year of becoming
a professional
magician, about how
to create not just experiences,
but create magical experiences,
something that I think
you guys-- probably
very relevant to
you guys at Google.
Now before I get into the
magical experiences part,
I want to talk to you guys
a little bit about-- I
want to answer the
question of how--
probably the second question
I get asked most often,
not how do you do it, but how
did you become a magician?
Now every magician you ask
will have a different story.
And mine begins with
me, nine years old,
laying on my family's
living room floor,
watching "Star
Wars" with my dad.
Now everyone here, I'm sure,
hopefully everyone here
has seen "Star Wars"--
fantastic movie.
And at nine years old, this was
the best movie I had ever seen.
Immediately, for the next
weeks after I thought
to myself, how can I
not become a magician,
but how do I become a Jedi?
I'm sure many of you guys
can empathize with that.
How do I become a Jedi?
It affected me so
strongly that I believed
that the force was
real after this.
I knew that it was obviously
exaggerated in "Star Wars"--
like I knew you
couldn't actually
lift a sinking x
wing out of a swamp.
But I knew that
there were people
on this earth who had the
ability to bend matter,
to manipulate matter with
their mind-- mind over matter.
And so after that, I decided
I had to do this myself.
I started thinking-- I imagined,
like, ancient Indian shamans
across the world who would
spend all their concentration
busking on street
corners, focusing
all their concentration
on lifting a penny
off a table, just
like a couple inches.
I knew that this
was possible and I
had to figure out how it
was done at nine years old.
I even went so far as
to go into the library
and find some books on
telekinesis, which is obviously
the ability to bend
matter with your mind.
I was a little bit
of an odd child.
And ultimately, I failed.
I failed, which was a shame.
But I didn't stop believing.
A few months later,
my parents brought me
and my sisters to Disneyland
for magical adventures.
And I don't know
if you guys know,
but you walk into Disneyland
and right on the right
there is the magic shop.
People have been to
this magic shop, I hope?
I've been to the magic shop.
And that day when we went
to Disneyland, my parents
brought us in, and you would
not believe the magic trick
that they showed us.
No, they did not
levitate a penny.
But they levitated--
this magician
in here levitated something
even better-- 100 times better,
in fact-- my dad's dollar bill.
The magician asked my father
to borrow a dollar bill.
My dad graciously lent
him a dollar bill.
And amazingly, the magician
took the dollar bill
and folded it right in half,
right in front of my eyes,
like this.
He just folded it right
in half, like that.
And then he just placed it
into the air, like that.
I was shocked.
He asked me to grab it.
So I snatched it out of
the air, opened it up.
There was nothing inside.
There was nothing in the
guy's hand and I was shocked.
I was, like, what?
Immediately, my mind went
back-- my nine-year-old mind
went back to "Star
Wars," the force, Jedis,
the Indian shamans on
the street corners.
And I thought, here, right
in front of me, here's
a man who has learned this
most impossible mental feat
of concentration and will.
And not only that, but
he was willing to sell it
to me for $14.99.
I had to have it.
So over the next two
days at Disneyland,
I convinced my parents
to buy me this secret.
And we went back at the end
of the trip to Disneyland.
And I handed the man the $15.
And he went back
behind the counter
to get what I imagined to be an
ancient, dusty manuscript with,
like, scribbled incantations,
like secret meditative scripts
on how you can control
matter with your mind.
And I was little
disappointed, to be honest,
to find a small,
folded piece of paper,
a little pamphlet
with staples in it
and a little plastic baggie
with a small amount of very
fine black thread.
My heart sank.
But it taught me a
very important lesson,
an important lesson
about secrets
and how the secret will never be
as valuable as the experience.
With that, I want
to give you guys
a magical experience
better than the dollar.
It's not really my forte.
But I'd like to give you
guys a magical experience.
Are we ready?
Yes?
OK.
So now, I asked earlier if-- I
was wondering just on myself,
by myself, like is it illegal to
have an iPhone on this campus?
I see people with
Apple computers.
Is it against the rules?
Because-- oh wow, OK.
Can we just-- just
for my curiosity,
how people are Android users?
Wow.
That is amazing.
How many people
are iPhone users?
Wow, OK.
Windows 7?
No?
Me either.
Now I'm doing--
yeah, back there?
We have one Windows 7 user.
I don't believe it.
So my performance
is based strongly
on audience participation.
And I want to begin right
now with an exercise
in non-randomness, an
exercise in non-randomness.
So would you mind-- wait,
was it you who had--
can I borrow your iPhone?
Oh, you who had the iPhone?
Sure.
Let's see here.
So I'm not going to
guess your passcode.
What's your passcode?
AUDIENCE: 1200.
KEVIN BLAKE: OK.
Easy as that, ladies
and gentlemen.
Easy as that.
Now I'm going to get
to the calculator app.
My favorite thing about
the calculator app
is that you can still use
it to write boobs with.
I don't know.
That doesn't hit
often because, like--
or it hits in different crowds.
We got a spattering of
laughter on that one.
I don't know if you, like,
some of the older people
used slide rules or something
in their math class.
I'm not quite sure.
Let's see here.
Boobs.
OK?
Nice.
Now I'm going to clear that.
So let's see here.
I want to talk to you guys
about-- so first of all,
I want you guys all
to get in your mind
a specific two
digits-- any two digits
that are somewhere in your life.
All right?
So that could be inside
of your passcode,
1200, or somewhere in your phone
number, your social security
number, your parents'
phone number.
So I want all of you guys to go
ahead and think of that right
now.
Go ahead and think
of that right now.
Just take a moment.
Sure.
All right.
So we'll go ahead
and clear that.
Now let's see.
So what are-- let's see
here-- your two digits?
9 7.
OK, cool.
Now you have two digits?
I don't want you
to tell me them.
All I want you to do is
type in Multiply, and then
your two digits.
So go ahead and
do that right now.
Don't press Equal.
OK, now I want you
to do the same thing.
Don't say anything.
Just type in Multiply, and then
your two digits and nothing
after.
Cool.
So that's three.
We're going to do two more.
Let's get back here.
So hit Multiply then
hit your two digits.
Awesome.
One more.
And so we have five
two-digit numbers.
I don't know who here
is like a math whiz.
But this should be somewhere
in the millions, hopefully.
Let's go, how about you.
So what I want you to do is
grab it, hit Multiply, your two
digits, and then
just press Equal.
And what do we have?
Got a big number?
I want you to go ahead and
read that out loud to me.
And I'm going to
write that down here.
AUDIENCE: 318 million.
KEVIN BLAKE: Hold on a second.
what is it?
AUDIENCE: 318 million--
KEVIN BLAKE: 318 million--
AUDIENCE: 8,000-- 816.
KEVIN BLAKE: 8,000?
So 0--
AUDIENCE: 008, and then 816.
KEVIN BLAKE: 816.
Great handwriting, I know.
So this is-- can you just
confirm that's the number, yes?
Can you go ahead and
do a screen shot?
You know how to do
that on the iPhone?
Did it work?
Cool.
Now I'm just going to
leave that right now.
Can I grab this back from you?
And you can go ahead
and hold onto that.
Thanks so much for
helping me out with that.
Now before I go
any further, I just
want to give this to someone.
This is today's prediction.
Inside this, before the
show, I wrote down something
that I hope's going
to happen today
we're going to
see-- I don't know,
but we're going to
see-- based on decisions
that you guys make.
So would you go ahead and do
me a favor and just take this
and hold on to it, make
sure no one messes with it?
You're trustworthy?
We've never met before.
I didn't tell you, like, switch
it with the other envelope?
No.
OK.
Now right now, I promised
you guys no card tricks
at the beginning.
But what I want to do
right now is do something
even better-- a coin trick.
Are we ready?
Ta-da!
No.
So I want to tell
you guys a story
about a coin, a man,
and a game of choices.
All right, so I'm just going
to place this right here.
So let's see here.
Hmm, a man.
You, sir.
What's your name?
RYAN: Ryan.
KEVIN BLAKE: Ryan.
OK.
Ryan.
This is a story about Ryan.
Yeah.
Ryan was a man much like
every other man he knew,
although he considered
himself far more interesting
and intelligent and
charming and witty
and attractive than
the other men he knew.
But this fact was not the
point d continues not to be.
Much like every other man he
knew-- how old are you, Ryan?
RYAN: 31.
KEVIN BLAKE: Ryan was
concerned-- concerned
about a lot of things.
Concerned about the
work he was going
to push off until next
week as a Google employee,
as a-- what do you do?
RYAN: Engineering.
KEVIN BLAKE: As an engineering.
You have a specific
type of engineering?
RYAN: Infrastructure.
KEVIN BLAKE: Infrastructure.
Do you work on secret projects?
RYAN: Not that secret.
KEVIN BLAKE: OK.
As an infrastructure
engineer, he
was concerned by his
troubling spending habits--
boozing three or
four nights a week,
eating out constantly,
spending money frivolously
on things like
driverless vehicles,
or whatever you guys spend
your money on over here.
Most concern of all,
however, to Ryan
was the fact he
was having a story
told about him at this very
moment to a group of Googlers,
and soon to be streamed
live over the internet.
At this moment,
Ryan was concerned.
He said, why did I not just tune
into the live stream, he said.
RYAN: Why did I not just
tune into the live stream?
KEVIN BLAKE: Did he have
to pick me, he went on.
RYAN: Did he have to pick me?
KEVIN BLAKE: I
love wheelbarrows.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN: I love wheelbarrows.
KEVIN BLAKE: Asparagus.
RYAN: Asparagus.
KEVIN BLAKE: Ryan
was an odd fellow.
Give Ryan a big
round of applause
as he joins me up on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN BLAKE: No, no, we're fine.
So as Ryan went up onto the
stage and took his place,
he noticed something
peculiar in front of him
on the ground, a
glimmer of silver,
a coin on the ground
a few feet away.
He bent over and picked it up.
He examined it.
A half dollar.
He gave it a flip
and listened to it
sing as it spun through the air.
He brought it up to
his ear and shook it.
What it was he was expecting
to hear, I cannot know.
Ryan, I'd like to play a game
with you-- a game of choices.
Do you think that you're
a fairly predictable type
of person?
Fairly predictable
type personality?
RYAN: Yeah, sure.
KEVIN BLAKE: Yeah?
Yeah?
Good.
You are aware, of
course, that as humans we
are pattern-seeking
creatures with brains
that have evolved
in order to analyze
our environments
for these patterns,
in order to sift through
the incredible barrage
of information hitting our
senses every second we live.
You know this?
RYAN: I do that, yes.
KEVIN BLAKE: Yes, exactly.
So you know that as
humans, we are predictable.
So you agree, you
are predictable.
RYAN: I'm very predictable.
KEVIN BLAKE: I'd like
to give you a chance
to prove yourself
right or wrong,
depending on what
you want to do.
So what I'm going
to do right now,
what we're going to play
right here is a game.
Can you step back a little bit?
We're going to play a game
involving your choices.
What I want you to do is place
the coin behind your back.
Don't place it into either hand.
Just hold it between
the two hands.
In a moment, I'm going
to ask you to place it
into one of your two hands.
And I'm going to try and guess
which hand you place it in.
If I do not correctly
guess five times in a row,
then you can win the dollar
bill that I floated earlier.
So just saying, this we
got a lot running on this.
So Ryan, right now I want
you to place the coin
into either of your two hands.
Now you can place it
in your left hand.
Audience, that's your right.
Or the hand that's
left, your right hand.
You following?
Great.
Now Ryan, go ahead
and just place-- no.
Face me.
Place the two-- place it
into one of your two hands.
Bring them out.
Excellent.
Bring them out like this.
Awesome.
Now what I want you to do--
face the audience, actually.
Now Ryan, I want you
to focus on which
hand you've placed the coin in.
Don't give anything away.
But if you did exactly
what I wanted you to do,
I think you would place
it in your right hand.
Please open your hand
and show everyone
that's it's in your right hand.
It is in your right hand.
Excellent.
So that's one out of one.
Not very impressive.
50-50 try.
One more time I want you
to go ahead and place it
behind your back.
And this time,
obviously, the question
is whether he should keep
in the same hand or switch.
Right?
If he keeps in the
same-- he knows
that only a fool would keep it
in the same losing hand twice.
Of course.
So obviously, the only thing
he can do is switch hands.
But he knows that I know that
only a fool would keep it
in the same hand twice.
And so he should switch hands.
So he knows that the only
thing he can do really
is to keep it in the same losing
hand a second time, right?
But of course you
know that I know
that he knows that I know
that-- you follow, right?
So you've made your choice.
Good.
So bring your two
hands back around.
Excellent.
Spread them out a little bit.
Now what I think
here is-- actually
go ahead and face the audience.
Audience, I want to
see if you guys can
tell the difference here.
A little closer together.
Now we have two--
go in the middle.
So the question is
whether he keeps it
in the same hand
or switches, right?
First one he kept it
in the right hand.
So if he thinks that
he should switch it,
you'd keep in your
left hand, right?
I think that you
would have placed it
in your-- in your-- left hand.
RYAN: Yep.
KEVIN BLAKE: OK.
So Two out of two.
Not very impressive.
That's only one out of four.
But you can try
it one more time.
We have three more tries.
So this time, I'm
going to tell you
exactly what I'm going to do.
I'm going to tell you--
I'm telling you right now--
that next time I'm going
to choose your left hand.
So just choose whatever
you want, left or right.
It doesn't really matter.
Just choose left to right.
Can you come a little closer?
Are you ready?
You've made your choice?
RYAN: I've made my choice.
KEVIN BLAKE: OK.
Bring them back around.
Bring them to my face.
Right there.
You remember what I said, right?
RYAN: Barely.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN BLAKE: I said
I was going to choose
your left hand, right?
So now the question is,
what kind of person is Ryan?
Is he the kind of person
who just goes along
with the motion, just kind
of does what people say?
And we can kind of think
that he is, in fact,
that kind of person
considering he
was so animated earlier
with saying "asparagus."
And yeah, I think you
would probably believe me
that I would choose
your left hand.
And, of course,
I'm not going to.
I'm going to choose
your right hand.
So go ahead and open it.
And that's three out of three.
OK.
So we have two more tries.
Two more tries.
So I'm not going to
say anything this time.
Just choose whichever
hand you want.
Audience, this is going
to be your responsibility
on this one.
So I'm kind of getting
out of the picture.
I'm hoping that you guys have an
intuitive understanding of what
he will choose.
So try and get in sync
with Ryan real fast.
So go ahead and choose.
You've chosen?
Bring your hands back around.
Now audience, a
round of applause.
Actually, let's just do this.
Everyone on the count of
three, just shout out-- all
hopefully the same-- which
hand you think it is.
So, one, two, three--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KEVIN BLAKE: Ooh, OK.
So much stronger on left, right?
So they think it's
in this hand, right?
The question is, is it in
this hand or this hand?
Let's do a little
bit different thing.
Let's go, round of applause for.
OK, so round of
applause for left hand.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN BLAKE: Now, round of
applause for the right hand.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN BLAKE: That
sounded fairly equal.
Yeah, I think so.
That's more applause than
I've gotten all day so far,
so that's good.
Well done.
And now I think, audience,
you got a split decision.
So I'm just going to
be the vote on this.
I think he chose his right hand.
So go ahead and open it.
And right hand one more time.
So that's four in a row.
Don't applaud.
Not impressive.
One more.
Thank you.
Excellent.
Boo is necessary.
So one more try.
This time, I won't
say anything again,
just other than whichever one
you want-- right or left, left
or right.
You can choose right
hand or the wrong hand.
Whatever you want to do.
[LAUGHTER]
You've made your choice.
You've made your choice?
RYAN: Yes.
KEVIN BLAKE: So once
again, bring them out.
I'm trying to see through
his hands at this point.
I think-- let's see.
So what was the pattern
we've had so far?
We had right, left, left,
right, right, right, left, left.
I don't-- wait.
So I think you chose-- I think
I know what hand you chose.
If I get it right, please
just hand me the coin
and re-take your seat
to thunderous applause,
all for you.
And I'm just going to go
ahead and just take this back.
I'm this confident.
So I think it is in your--
once again, in your right hand.
So go ahead and place it.
And that's it, right hand.
And give him a big round of
applause as he takes his seat.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN BLAKE: OK.
Thank you so much, Ryan,
for dealing with that.
I appreciate that a lot.
And thank you guys all so much
for enjoying that with me.
So I love magic.
Who here loves magic?
Who here loves magicians?
No?
Yeah, me either.
So magic recently has gotten a
lot more popular in the past 10
years or so, based off of
all these shows, TV specials,
movies, and that kind of thing.
But it's still a sad truth that
magic in general is filled with
bad illusions, socially
awkward, look-at-what-I-can-do
performers, and
witless presentations.
Magic in general
is a fantastic art,
but there are a lot
of problems in it.
And I want to talk to
you about a few of those,
but I also want
to talk about how
to create magical experiences.
Now I don't blame people
for feeling somewhat
negative toward the art
of magic in general.
Because often, it seems like
a lot of magical presentations
that people see do
one of two things.
Either they're not
challenging intellectually--
they insult you and
your intelligence
by pretending that you
don't know that there's
a string floating the
dollar, or the magician
gives you the impression
that he expects
you to believe that
he actually holds
the powers that his
illusions are replicating.
This kind of insults
your intellect,
like you know that
he's not a wizard.
This is clear.
He's an illusionist.
Either that, or
magic is presented
as a puzzle that pits the
audience against the magician
in some sort of
twisted battle of wits
where if the magician
fools you, you lose.
If he doesn't, then the
magic is ruined, right?
None of these are ideal.
Now that being said,
I do believe strongly
that magic has the
potential to be
a very intellectual
and serious art form.
And that's because
what magic ultimately
deals with is something
very, very powerful, and that
is the nature of
truth-- what is reality.
What is our reality?
At any moment, at
any given time,
the most important
basic belief you form
is what is real--
what is my reality.
And it's from this belief
that we form all of our others
and if we make errors in
this judgment, obviously
can have very dire consequences.
When I'm walking into
Google across the street,
if I make an error in
my judgment of reality
and I don't see the car
coming, obviously bad things.
If I err consistently in less
physically perilous ways,
mental ways, psychological
ways, I'm a schizophrenic.
This "what is real"
is one of our most
central and
foundational beliefs.
And it's always
humming along right
under our level of
conscious awareness.
And I think it can be with
magic, a very profound thing.
Profound, but not the point.
The key to creating
magical experiences
is not to convince your audience
that they may or may not
be sane.
The key to creating magical
experiences, I think, is this.
So number one, we must
understand the assumptions
and expectations
of our audience.
Pencils, please?
Number two, we must break these
expectations and assumptions.
And number three,
we must break them
in a way that brings people
joy and also makes them
question just what
is possible to have
happen in an experience.
Now as much as we all
like to think of ourselves
as logical and rational
beings, we only
have to look so far as our
news headlines, even ourselves,
when in anger or in love or
drunk or whatever, to realize
how wrong of an
assumption this is.
No matter how much we like
to praise our rational side,
there's no arguing that we
are ruled by our emotions.
We are ruled by our emotions.
And it's important to--
well, and sometimes this
can be a very bad thing,
because sometimes we
find ourselves acting in ways
that we don't want to act,
or not being able to do the
things that we want to do.
For example, we all know
that it's important to floss
twice a day, that we
should eat healthy
and that we should exercise
and we should save money.
And yet, how many of us
actually do these things?
I don't.
I don't know about you.
Maybe you guys are better
individuals than I.
As we all are, as people who
create experiences for others,
it's vital to know
and understand
this gap between the logic
and the emotional side
and what is the
most strong pull?
Obviously, emotion.
Now also of course,
what's the best way
to engage with someone's
emotional side?
Now I, if you remember,
break expectations.
Number two, right?
I think surprising people by
breaking their expectations is
the most powerful way to engage
with their emotional side.
And this makes sense,
surprising is it breaks you out
of your day-to-day assumptions.
Now of course,
surprise is powerful.
But surprise in general is
not necessarily a good thing.
If I ask, who likes
to be surprised,
it's like, very few
people like surprises.
But that's because most the
time when you guys engage
with surprises it's
a negative thing.
If my friend expects me to
pick him up from the airport
and I surprise him by not
picking him up at the airport,
this is not an
enjoyable experience.
But if I, say, surprise him
by bringing him a sandwich
because he'll be
hungry from his flight,
or bringing two of
his best friends
along to surprise-- like,
these are good experiences.
So that being said,
obviously the surprises
that we embed in the experiences
we create need to be positive.
Google Doodles is a
great example of this.
Search is a very
neutral experience.
You're trying to find someone.
It's a road to where
you actually want to be.
And yet you-- someone
in this campus, maybe
not you specifically--
has decided
that it would be a great
idea to inject a little joy
bomb in this experience.
And it's wonderful.
Now unfortunately,
people expect the doodle,
so it's not so much
of a surprise anymore.
But still, it is a great
example of something
that you can embed.
Now as a magician whose
illusions depend on the choices
that people make, of course
I have to be aware of
and anticipate the
expectations and assumptions
that my audiences
will have when they
go into an experience
with myself.
But that doesn't mean-- it's
no less important for anyone
who creates
experiences to do this.
You guys should all
actually probably be
much more aware of these
expectations and assumptions
that your audiences will
have in the experience
that you create,
because the experiences
that you deliver-- mine start
when you walk into the theater
and when you walk out.
Yours-- Google,
social media, Gmail,
Maps-- all these things
are embedded in our lives
to the point where they
are part of who we are.
Our phone buzzes, people are
getting phantom vibrations.
Our phones are so
connected to us.
So it's even more
important to be
aware of these expectations,
embed surprises, and embed joy,
but not only that,
make you feel as
if you're living in the future.
And i think this is one of the
things that Google is best at,
and other companies
in the tech world
are very good at, best at.
For example, I can open
my phone, press a button,
and watch a car come pick me up
and know exactly how much it's
going to cost and
how long it's going
to take to get to
my friend's house.
This is, to the taxi hailing
era, a magical experience.
I'd like to leave you guys with
just one of my favorite quotes
that I think is extremely
relevant for you guys.
"Any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable
from magic."
This is Arthur C. Clarke--
"2001: A Space Odyssey" guy.
And I think it's a great
pithy statement of what
it is that you guys
should be trying to do
and I think that
you guys are doing.
So with that, thank you guys so
much for watching and enjoying
this with me.
Yes, the envelope.
Right.
So in a moment, we're going
to get to the envelope.
Thank you guys so much for
listening to that part.
This is back to a little bit--
one final magical experience,
I hope.
So in a moment I'm
going to ask you
to just go ahead
and have this mike.
is this on?
We'll see.
So in a moment, I just want
you to stand up, please.
Open it, and read out
what it is inside.
And I'm hoping that it will
correspond with-- so just right
when I-- just go ahead and open
it and just read what's inside.
I'm hoping that this is good.
I think it will be.
Oh, boy.
That's this fine.
So thank you so much for coming.
And I hope you guys
have a wonderful rest
of your Thursday.
No, actually, hold on a second.
I think we do.
We can salvage this.
So we have the numbers, right?
318,008,816?
So I wanted to
deliver to you guys
one last magical
experience and it's this.
I'm going to transform
your experience right now.
So this is the prediction.
Today, Google.
Who sees it?
So that's 918-- Google.
That's today and right now.
So thank you guys
so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You can go ahead
and sit back down.
Thanks very much.
So we are going to have a
Q&A, if anyone has questions.
We're going to have a
Q&A. So feel free to stay.
If you don't want to stay,
if you're sick of it,
you don't have any questions
and you don't want any answers,
get the hell out of here.
But if not, please yeah.
I should point out
quickly that this is not
going to be a
traditional Q&A. This
is not going to be
Q&A. This is going
to be Q&AA, which is questions
and attempted answers.
So I promise you, I'm not--
I'm going to try my best
but I won't reveal
any secrets to you.
And I may not know any answers.
So yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: This is a very simple
question, not a profound one.
And I think you will have an A--
KEVIN BLAKE: I hope so.
AUDIENCE: --which
is, how old are you?
Why are you not very old?
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN BLAKE: How old am I?
I'm 24.
AUDIENCE: That's it?
Then why don't you
have long hair,
like magicians are
supposed to have long hair?
KEVIN BLAKE:
Because I'm breaking
expectations and assumptions.
Are magicians supposed
to have long hair?
AUDIENCE: And the cape too.
KEVIN BLAKE: Oh, yes.
So these are the
expectations and assumptions
I was talking about, right?
One of the reasons I don't
like to call myself a magician
is because people assume that
I'm going to have long hair,
wear a cape, have a cane,
and a pet bunny rabbit,
which I'm working on.
Is that your-- you
have another question?
AUDIENCE: The follow-up
question is, how did you
get into this, what fascinates
you, and what keeps you here?
KEVIN BLAKE: Well,
what fascinates me
about-- I mean, I
hope to have answered
a few of those questions
in the presentation.
But I suppose what fascinates
me about magic in large part
is the experience of what
is possible versus what
is impossible.
I think it's a
really powerful thing
to be able to break
people's expectations
and to show them something and
have them jarred really quickly
out of their just kind
of neutral baseline
level of experience.
Another thing that
fascinates me about magic,
one of my favorite
parts about it,
is how it makes people fools.
I love more than anything else
being deceived by something
because it shows
me my ignorance.
I think magic is
one of the best ways
to learn what it is about your
perceptions and your level
of attention that
are completely false.
People can be fooled-- everyone.
And that has implications
on so many spectrums,
from the skepticism spectrum
of God doesn't exist
and religion and
alternative medicine
and stuff all the way to
just day-to-day things,
not being aware of the
intentions of people
you're hanging out with,
like that kind of stuff.
So I think it does
have a lot of meaning
behind it and importance.
AUDIENCE: I think one of
the points you brought up
was about the expectations
or the cool sign stuff.
One of the kids' class I was
there and said, hey magic,
look.
There's a device here which
I can press a few buttons,
talk to and see somebody
around the world.
And people are like, "So what?"
The kids, basically,
they have-- they
don't think that I do magic.
So that's a very
good point, like this
could have been actually the
grand magic 100 years ago
if you had shown somebody.
KEVIN BLAKE: Oh yeah.
I mean, all the technology
that we live in right
now is completely
impossible, or just comes
so out of the realm
of imagination
of a human of 100 years ago.
It is just mind
boggling what we can do.
AUDIENCE: So what I find
fascinating is the small tricks
you do still fascinates people
versus they are completely
oblivious to the fact which
is, you are living under magic
which was not possible 100 years
ago or something like this--
fly around the world
and go somewhere and--
KEVIN BLAKE: I think one of
the challenges of magic right
now is trying to continue to
evolve alongside technology.
Because a lot of
things-- and that's
one of the problems with
the magician assuming-- what
I said earlier-- like a
magician assuming that you know
or expecting you to believe
that he has magical powers.
Like, it's insulting to watch a
magician perform and then feel
as though he wants you to
believe that he can levitate
something or to stick
a spike through a woman
or to have-- at this
age of technology
and advanced technology
and that kind of stuff,
we have a very large
understanding of what
is impossible and
what's possible.
Now we all know you cannot
levitate something with
your mind.
You can't do that.
And so I think one
of the challenges is,
and one of the
challenges that magic
a struggling with in large
part, in a lot of areas,
is these magicians who
continue to perform
these rudimentary and
old-style-- impressive
when we didn't have such
an understanding of what
the world is like, but
not impressive anymore.
Floating a little
ball on a handkerchief
like you know that
that can't work.
So it doesn't impress anymore.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, what
are the magicians
that you particularly admire
and aspire to be as good as?
KEVIN BLAKE: So one
magician I admire and aspire
to be as good as,
hopefully, is right here.
David Gerard-- everyone,
David Gerard right here.
Google magician extraordinaire.
DAVID GERARD: I have a badge.
KEVIN BLAKE: David's
a fantastic magician.
I saw him a few weeks
ago at the Magic Castle
when he was performing
there with a friend of his.
And he has a wonderful,
wonderful performance.
So I recommend you
all go see his.
In terms of famous
magicians, there's one--
[LAUGHTER]
In terms of famous
magicians, of course
we have very few that you
guys probably would know.
A man who is a huge
inspiration to me
is a man named Darren Brown.
Does anyone here know who
Darren Brown is, except for him?
Yeah?
We got a few?
Two?
So you'll know he's
amazing, is he not?
He is a Englishman,
a British guy
who does similar psychological
hypnotism, all sorts
of incredible presentations
that involve magic but are not
just magic.
They go way beyond it.
So I highly recommend
you check him out.
He is awesome.
And he definitely inspired me
and almost every other magician
that you'll run into these days.
AUDIENCE: So sorry.
I missed the first part.
How early in your life
you started doing this?
KEVIN BLAKE: I got into magic,
as I said, when I was nine.
But I didn't actually
start doing magic
until I was maybe, like, 12.
And then that my first
actual public performance
was in high school.
My first full theater
show was in college.
And so I am very new at
this in terms of stage time.
I've only put on about, maybe,
30 shows, 30 full shows.
And I hope to continue to
improve and to perform more.
AUDIENCE: Talking about
manipulating audiences,
what is the most surprising
thing an audience has
done to you?
KEVIN BLAKE:
Interesting question.
Surprising thing an audience
has done to me-- well,
I think probably
about two years ago, I
was performing a routine
that maybe some of you guys
have seen on, like, "America's
Got Talent" or something, where
someone has a bunch
of-- a big spike
under either in paper bags
or like under styrofoam cups.
And I was performing
this routine
and you smash the ones that
it's not in, obviously,
and with the one that
it's in unsmashed.
So I was doing this
with a woman on stage
who was helping me out.
And there's a safety
mechanism built
into the trick where hopefully
if it's about to go wrong,
she will stop me.
And the audience also will
hopefully scream and stuff.
This didn't happen.
There was no safety mechanism,
and I stabbed myself
in the hand with a nail.
So that was-- but
continued the show.
The show must go on.
And what was worse is
that I had asked someone
in the audience who was
medically trained to help me
out.
I had it first aid kit.
I still got it right in
here, a first aid kit.
I said, do you know
how to bandage someone?
Good.
It's supposed to all be for
show, build the tension.
No.
She didn't know
how to bandage me.
She lied about being
first aid trained,
and I was just like, help
me out with the bandage.
And she says, I don't
know how to do it.
And I was like, OK
I'll do it myself
and then continued the
show and kicked her out.
So that was the show.
Yeah, questions?
MALE SPEAKER: You
told that story
when I saw you and I
thought it was a joke
and I thought it was
part of the show.
KEVIN BLAKE: It's very serious.
Very serious.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
the one we did with the coin,
if you've ever had
anyone while they
have their hands
behind their back--
KEVIN BLAKE: Win a dollar?
Put it in their pocket.
AUDIENCE: Put it
in their pocket?
KEVIN BLAKE: Yeah.
Read your mind.
Yes, this has happened.
And hopefully, by
the way that they act
and the little smirk on
their face, you can guess.
Often when I'm doing
this, I'll say,
you didn't put it in
your pocket did you?
And they'll say, oh, I did.
And it's a win, right?
But I didn't do that
this time because I
was so confident with you, Ryan.
So yes, this is
something does happen.
But there are ways
to get around that.
AUDIENCE: So do you watch for
facial expressions and Paul
Ekman and "Lie To Me"
and all that stuff?
KEVIN BLAKE: I don't watch
the show "Lie To Me."
But a part of the
stuff that I've
tried to learn as a
magician, because I
think it very much makes
your performance better,
is to be able to
read your audience
and read your participant.
So the people who
come on a stage,
it's vitally important to watch
what they're doing, how they're
acting, and then use
that to your advantage,
whether calling out
different things, like I'm
sure all of you guys saw when
I said, left or I said right.
I don't remember which.
But you gave a huge
little half smirk.
Huge little-- sorry about that.
You gave a very obvious
little twitch of your mouth.
Did we see this?
I saw it.
I don't know how obvious
this is to audiences.
But this kind of thing
is very, very good
to call out during
a show or to seem
as though you're
using that to predict.
So yeah, it's part
of the training
but it's definitely
not everything.
MALE SPEAKER: Also is
there any plug I can give?
mindofkevin.com And if
there are any shows--
KEVIN BLAKE: Yeah, you can
find tickets and show dates
for the show that I
perform in San Francisco.
Sorry, not around here
for those of you guys
who live around here.
Shows in San Francisco, next
one's I think in November.
But I do them relatively often,
like once or twice a month.
You can find this stuff on
my website, mindofkevin.com.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
KEVIN BLAKE: Thank
you guys so much.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]